one of my favorite segments of the week
is when people take my buddy Kevin Smith
and put him in inappropriate places via
the magic of Photoshop it's known as
[Music]
let's see what's kept in this week this
week we take a look at the history of
Kevin's career not as a screenwriter and
director as many of you may know him
best but as an actor a lot of you don't
know that Kevin started out as a child
actor here's Kevin in his very first
role I believe it was playing the role
of Elliott in the et I don't know if you
guys knew that Kevin was Kevin as a
Bullock was actually the childhood Chum
of et the extra-terrestrial in the
Steven Spielberg classic I did not know
that you had that role Facebook of me at
age 14 yeah you you were young if you
look real closely notice that you look
good in overalls you should think about
that as a look Kevin of course his
career blew up after that he went on to
work with many directors including John
Landis not many people know that he was
the best friend to David not in an
American Werewolf in London yeah they
are on the moors stay off the Moors
around
yeah and then Kevin as an actor grew and
of course he worked for many many years
most recently you probably have seen him
in looper with Bruce Willis and have you
seen that film Willis looks like he's
enjoying choking the [ __ ] out of you in
that scene I can't imagine why
[Music]
you
[Music]